saw this story over the weekend Ariel
Helwani the reporter for MMA fighting
calm got escorted out of an event and I
don't I think he was banned for life
because he broke the story about Brock
Lesnar coming back to UFC so Paulie said
let's reach out to Arielle and give him
a chance to talk about what happened and
he joins us now so where were you
Saturday night Arielle well then again
thank you so much for having me on the
show and I really appreciate you know
your support and and pol support as well
I was at the fabulous forum in Inglewood
California I was there to cover UFC 199
when all of this happen okay and you
reported Brock Lesnar's coming back to
UFC coming out of retirement yeah at
around 4:30 p.m. Pacific time I reported
that Conor McGregor and Nate Diaz were
close to finalizing their fight at UFC
202 now this was a little different
because usually when I'm reporting news
I'm usually you know at home or no-tell
room racing you know something like that
but this time I was in the media room
but as you know you know news doesn't
stop for any occasion when there's news
when you can confirm something you
report it so that was at around 4:30
p.m. Pacific time and in fact a PR
person came up to me and and told me
that I jumped the gun with that story
and I said that I was you know pretty
confident that it was right and in fact
a couple hours later they confirmed that
it was true at around 5 p.m. Pacific
time I reported that Brock lesner was
close to finalizing a deal to fight at
UFC 200 and this was a much bigger story
because it came out of the new out of
the blue no one suspected this because
he's under contract with with WWE and
this sort of you know blew up two into a
big thing and a lot of people thought I
was wrong for the record I'm still
batting 1,000 I've never been wrong with
anything as far as what I've reported at
around 11:00 or so right before the main
event a PR person came up to me and said
that Dana White wanted to speak to me
backstage and I told him that the main
event was coming up and I wanted to
watch it I have to you know cover it so
maybe we can talk afterwards I had been
told that he was a little
that this Brock lesner news got out a
couple minutes later another PR person
came and said you need to come to the
back to speak to Dana I said I'd like to
bring someone with me I brought my
videographer Casey Lydon with me and
Dana was standing in the back there and
said you know get out of here you're
done you're not welcome here he said go
to Bellator go cover Bellator which is
the the number two promotion in the
United States he said that you're too
negative
he said that Lorenzo Fertitta is not a
fan of yours and he made the call to
kick you out and you're not welcome here
ever again I tried to explain to him
that I was not doing anything negative
that I was doing the same thing that
every sports journalist does I got
something confirmed and I reported it a
PR person told me that I should have had
the professional courtesy to run that by
them but there's nowhere in the rulebook
that says that I have to do that as long
as it's you know confirmed by multiple
sources and good sources and I was right
I don't have to ask him because in the
past when I've asked them things they've
told me not to do it or if they you know
they said it's not true in fact ESPN
asked him about this story on Friday
night and he said it wasn't true so the
same thing would have happened and so
you know I thanked him for everything
he's done and I said you know I hope
that you'll reconsider
they took my credential away and they
they escorted us out of the building
that's that's the general gist of what
happened physically escorted you out of
the building well no one touched me but
they took us to the back we gathered our
things and they watched us very closely
I wasn't gonna do anything I have no
regrets I I would report the same thing
all over again but no one actually like
physically took me out but they walked
aside and waited for us to you know
leave the parking lot and all that
someone was there the entire time from
the UFC how upset was Dana White he was
pretty upset you know I've seen him
upset before he was he was very red you
know the funny thing is is that I've
always had a very good relationship for
the most part with Dana White it's maybe
been a little rocky or these days and
and maybe I'm just dreaming here but I
felt like deep down inside he didn't
really want to do this you know as you
know PR people and you know the
organization and and and media they're
not always going to see eye to eye
because you know I'm reporting stuff
perhaps before they want it out and you
know they want to they want to put it
out there
certain way they had a promo and all
that stuff so I know that he was a
little bit upset I don't know if he
wanted to go to this length I don't know
if he wanted to ban me necessarily again
maybe that's me just dreaming but he did
say on multiple times that this was
Lorenzo's decision that Lorenzo was not
a fan of mine and that again I'm too
negative and that he hates me and and
that I'm done and he said you know
you're finished you're not going to
cover this organization ever again but
what happened prior to this aerial is it
it's this you didn't do anything that
was negative you you ruined their party
you broke the news before they could
announce this on their own but how is
that negative and were there any other
incidents that led up to this because
you know let's not kid anybody Fox
dropped you and why would they why would
they drop you is the mm a journalist of
the year unless they were getting
pressure from UFC and Dana White
oh yeah well Fox dropped me because the
UFC told them to then 100% fact so you
know look for for a long time I was
working for Fox around four and a half
years and I have another job for MMA
fighting comm which is owned by Vox
media and when I was doing suffer for
Fox you know it was all UFC UFC when I'm
doing stuff for MMA fighting I'm talking
about the other organizations I'm
talking about
Bellator I'm talking about free agency
you know this sport is evolving very
quickly and there's a lot of new things
happening I think we spoke about that
you know the last time I was on and so I
was being told over the last few months
or so that they were getting
increasingly annoyed that I was you know
I guess out scooping them but again I
feel almost awkward and and and
embarrassed about all this because I'm
not doing some great investigative
journalism here I'm not gonna win a
Pulitzer for any of this doesn't work
I'm just I'm just reporting fights and
if that's negative I mean then what are
we all doing here why are they sorting I
understand though I mean this they don't
want to be covered by traditional media
well this is and this is not you know an
isolated incident other journalists have
have you know unfortunately had to deal
with this I don't think it was anything
on on this sort of level when it was
just like you know reporting a fight in
and you're out I'm not naive as you
alluded to I know that this has been
brewing for quite some time but again I
I highly disagree and it's funny a lot
of people
including the dead spins of the world
used to call me a shill and you know
just like a puff piece reporter and now
all of a sudden I'm this you know this
martyr for journalism and all I was
doing was reporting was reporting fights
and you know if you can't do that and I
don't know really what they want you
know there's that famous quote you know
news is what someone wants us to wants
to be suppressed everything else is just
advertising and I think that they just
want advertising at this point they just
want people to report like Brock lesner
was just on with Hannah Storm and he
announced his opponent and they just
want people to go off that they don't
want anyone to try to dig deep in it
where I come from and I graduated from
Newhouse they tell you to go out there
and find the news and especially when
you know the news is coming you're not
doing your job if you're not reporting
it and that's that's what I was doing on
Saturday and I wouldn't do it any
differently do you want us to apply for
a credential for the next fight you can
be the Dan Patrick MMA correspondent
you know I appreciate that in you know
you you you probably know this but it's
important for me to say for people like
you to even give me the time of day
going through something like this is
very important because this stuff
doesn't happen necessarily in other
sports and this is I think at this point
a little bit bigger than me it's time
that you know the mainstream media knows
that this stuff happens in in mixed
martial arts and particularly in the UFC
you know I was with my two colleagues
who are the best of what they do Casey
Lydon and Esther Lynn photojournalist
video journalist they had nothing to do
with this and they were kicked out as
well why you know what did they you know
that that to me is is not right and I
know that getting a credential is you
know a privilege as they put it but you
know it's 2016 and the sport has come a
long way and if this can happen to me
then I'm pretty sure that it could
happen to any other journalist trying to
cover the sport as well and that's
really what I think is important here so
while I appreciate that gesture I have a
feeling that at this point and hopefully
I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong I don't know
at this point they'd probably deny that
even if it's you Arielle thanks for
joining us thanks for keeping us up to
date as well we appreciate it thank you
for everything done I really appreciate
it Ariel Helwani MMA fighting comm the
Dan Patrick show we
on audience